well the Twitter and Instagram and
Facebook world is alive and buzzing with
a couple of stories just dying for Dave
Ramsey to say something about so I will
first is Apple comes out with a credit
card this week and everybody's freaking
out don't freak out I'm not I don't hate
Apple I have an Apple iPhone that I my
personal phone I have one of the iPads
and my personal computers Adel but you
know I mean Apple makes some really good
products and Apple pay wasn't making
them as much money as they needed and
they're only the wealthiest company in
the whole freaking world they needed
some more so they come out with a credit
card and there's nothing pregnant about
the credit card it's a credit card and
it doesn't have a few fees but it's got
a you know 13 to 24 percent interest
rate it's a credit card stupid is it's
no difference just Apple has a credit
card now but they have more money than
Egypt they're bigger than most banks so
why can't they have a credit card does
that mean you need to use it Lord no we
can use some of their other fine
products but why would you fall for that
crap you're gonna go in dad at 24%
because Tim Cook told you to only if
you're stupid I mean but something but
they do have tremendous they have such
good products if tremendous brand
loyalty and they'll be able to extend
that and get people into debt now I
don't a credit card and that it'll work
it'll work great for them they'll make a
ton of money off of you so I mean I've
had about it'll be like saying I mean I
don't know who ever a bank has a credit
card that makes a bazillion dollars on
you I mean they still cut it up this is
titanium so it'll take a pair of like
cutting shears or something I won't you
won't do it the simple scissors or you
put it in there in your shredder
shredder it'll probably blow your
shredder up but you know so yeah if you
I mean if you're just such an Apple geek
you're just geeked
that you really want to give them some
more money well they're gonna give you
an opportunity here and that's all it is
the other thing that's going crazy on
the Internet is CNBC posted a budget of
this couple making a half million
dollars a year that couldn't seem to
make it they were an average couple
which shows how in touch CNBC is but and
everybody's want me to trash these
people
I don't trash but if you know Dave
Ramsey it's a whole this he'll rip them
and I'm like I'm not listen I don't
answer questions that aren't asked if
those people call me and ask me well
yeah I could tell them how to live on
half million dollars I think you could
too and that's been the funny part of
reading the posts all over the place the
Twitter posts the Facebook posts another
thing is that you folks can look at that
budget and go well that's absurd I mean
you you can help them balance their
budget I mean cuz none of you are in
Congress so you know how to balance a
budget you know you know how to live on
less than you make you look at it and
you go yeah I think they could sell this
and I think they could cut that and you
know I think the same thing and but I'm
not gonna rip those poor people to
shreds they're getting they're getting
destroyed in social media though they're
getting lit up man I mean it's crazy so
you go viral for all the wrong reasons
you know so so no I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna pile on that either I mean I would
never tell you use a credit card and
apples not special it's just a stupid
credit card and I don't I don't answer
questions that aren't asked and so I
don't jump into media phrase and tell
people who didn't ask me how to live now
if you call and ask me that I'm supposed
to answer the question that's the
relationship I have with you and I won't
tell you what's smart what's stupid and
how you can win and what you can do and
that kind of stuff so I don't do that
one of the things I tell you to do is
never buy a stupid timeshare right
because they're stupid ninety three
percent of people buy a timeshare which
they didn't have one they feel ripped
off it's an absolutely horrible product
it's always sold in some pressure cooker
situation where you went you thought you
were going to get a free room and the
free room you got was locked in with a
Salesman in a free room until you
bought something that was your free room
and so you end up with a timeshare
$14,000 finance that you never go and
then the fees go up every year so we've
been helping you get out of those so I
don't know if you know the story on
Florida or not I'm a big fan of Florida
I like Florida
there's a lot of cool things about
Florida but sometimes Florida does some
stupid butt stuff and they're getting
ready to do one right now so the story
on flower you ever heard the story I got
some swampland to sell you in Florida
you ever heard that saying I could sell
you some swamp if you believed that I
could sell you some swampland in Florida
means you're a sucker a sucker is born
every minute you know that's saying it's
the same thing and the reason was there
was a bunch of land scams in Florida
back in the day in the 40s and 50s where
people would go down there kind of like
I'm an old and daytime share except at
what a timeshare it was just a land scam
and they would sell you two acres of
land that was swamp as you know sight
unseen I bought Florida property and you
didn't know what you were doing and you
got scammed it was a real thing people
got sold swampland in Florida and
Florida became kind of known for ripping
people off as a state in the name of
having a vacation spot and the course
they cleaned the act up and the real
estate laws got into place and they you
know they they started you know
requiring people to not commit fraud and
all this kind of stuff and so you know
swampland in Florida I'll show you some
of you believe that I'll sell you some
swampland in Florida I got some
swampland in Florida I'll show you
became a saying because it actually
happened in Florida had a bad reputation
as a place to get scammed well one of
the top timeshare locations in America
of course is Florida so it's one of the
top places you can get scammed and
instead of fixing that some idiot has
been bought out by the timeshare
industry down there and has now put a
bill bill four three five on the floor
so listen to me Florida let your state
legislators know that you don't be known
for scam artists they put a
bill on the floor or they just trying to
get it to the floor to ban timeshare
exit teams from coming in they're like
our timeshare exit team to ban people
from coming in and helping people get
out of being ripped off on a timeshare
instead of regulating the rip-off
timeshare industry they're trying to
regulate the people who are getting
people out of timeshares and keep them
from operating there now Florida you
gotta have more sense than that it makes
you look scummy I mean you're going back
to the swampland days here you got to do
better so if you focus live in Florida
let your state legislature know that you
don't really want to be known for
scamming people and protecting the
people that are scamming people
for God's sakes that's like passing
legislation you know government
subsidizing payday lenders or something
kind of morons I mean that's the dumbest
thing the bills four three five if you
want to tell them what you think of it I
just told you what I think of it I think
whoever put that bill on the floor is
bought and owned by the timeshare ripoff
people yeah that's unbelievable
unconscionable